c'est un peu l'histoire du village
gaulois qui résiste encore et toujours à
l'envahisseur et qui a peur que le ciel
ne lui tombe sur la tête envoie de
déploiement dans le monde entier le
projet et starling rencontre quelques
oppositions en france les 17 députés du
groupe parlementaire de la france
insoumise ont déposé un amendement dans
le cadre de l'examen du projet de loi de
lutte contre le dérèglement climatique
il souhaite ouvrir un débat sur le
projet d'elon musk avant que la france
ne donne son autorisation
un moratoire sur le déploiement de
starling sur le territoire français est
décrété ce projet ne pourra être lancée
qu'à la condition d'un avis favorable de
la population française résultant d'une
consultation nationale menée à travers
tout le territoire français pendant au
moins un an
le projet est titanesque placer quelques
quarante deux mille satellites en orbite
autour de la terre pour offrir une
connexion internet haut débit partout
sur la planète
intitulé sterling qu'il s'agit d'un des
projets les plus ambitieux du
milliardaire américain et l'odm est ce
qu une innovation qui soulève cependant
quelques questions d'abord il ya la
pollution lumineuse provoqué par la
présence trop importante de satellites
un souci dénoncée notamment par des
astronomes pour qu'il devient de plus en
plus compliqué d'observer le ciel tant
il est encombrée par les trajectoires
satellitaire autre problème relevé par
les députés insoumis celui de la
consommation du projet sterling en
ressources naturelles
avec 42 mille satellite placé en orbite
ce sont des quantités astronomiques de
métaux rares et de carburants qui sont
nécessaires à leur envoi dans l'espace
de plus comme nous vous en parlions déjà
en décembre dernier l'activité
satellitaire est telle que les risques
de collision sont plus fréquents la
problématique question des débris serait
plus que jamais à l'ordre du jour avec
la mise en place de cette constellation
satellitaire souhaité par elon musk
enfin l'autre inquiétude qui découpe du
projet sterling et celle des antennes
relais nécessaires à son fonctionnement
ainsi la commune normande de saint
senier de beuvron a été choisi par le
milliardaire pour implanter ces fameuses
antennes 9 d'eau
pourrait être installé sur un terrain
agricole mais la municipalité a adopté
un arrêté d'opposition les élus locaux
comme les agriculteurs s'inquiètent en
effet de l'impact de ces antennes haute
technologie c'est un projet qui
éthiquement et inacceptable et un projet
qui démocratiquement tel qu'il nous le
plante là est dangereux il est inutile
il ne servira qu business de la
communication par la robotisation de
notre société par la rapidité d'internet
mais aujourd'hui ici à sa saignée
devrons nous avons internet
nous avons tous les moyens de
communication nous sommes sur les
réseaux sociaux
parce que musk doit savoir que ça existe
déjà malgré ses réticences l'arcep le
gendarme des télécoms a déjà donné son
feu vert
il y a également peu de chances que
l'amendement des députés insoumis soit
finalement conservé certains rétorquent
aux opposants que même si la france ne
donne pas son accord les satellites de
starling finiront bien par être placé en
orbite en lui refusant l'accès à son
réseau l'hexagone aurait finalement les
inconvénients sans les avantages
reste que la question de la
privatisation de l'espace est ici au
coeur du problème les avantages que
pourraient apporter l'offre de starlink
font plutôt consensus à savoir connecter
aux réseaux locaux les zones blanches
sur l'ensemble de la planète mais la
question est de savoir à quel prix déjà
le théâtre de nouvelles tensions
géopolitiques avec par exemple
l'investissement de l'armée américaine
l'espace devient un lieu stratégique le
saturer c'est forcément s'exposait à des
conséquences à moyen ou long terme
et si rien ne semble arrêter les
ambitions d'elon musk on peut au moins
légitimement se demander si les citoyens
n'ont pas leur mot à dire car jusqu'à
preuve du contraire le ciel n'a pas été
privatisée du moins pour l'instant